[Música]
então galera a única coisa
verdadeiramente nossa assim nessa vida
na história né
o resto das coisas vai morrer vai ficar
aí mas nossa história não é a nossa
história de produção dessas memórias do
tipo já que a gente fala o gerente se
veste de quem te ama
não espero que a gente é né e digo pra
saber que avançou foi um corre viu
tem coisa que a gente devia aprender em
casa assim depois de uma amiga galera do
dia e ela sempre me falava que os pais
dela falavam da história do sobrenome
dela que o tataravô dela veio da polônia
e toda aquela história eo primeiro falei
do doente marginalizado amélia ela falou
não sei
e de que país a gente veio também não
sei eu fiquei naquela hora fui pesquisar
no google eu vi que o nome era na
verdade até de uma família judia aí eu
fui ver que os senhores de engenho
colocavam os seus nomes nos escravos e
por isso que a gente não sabia qual era
o nosso sobrenome e nem de que país a
gente veio e mesmo sem minha mãe saber
de onde vem meu tataravô ela não
desistiu de deixar saber minha história
e como é que eles fizeram isso
do jeito que a gente mais gostava
através da cultura menina a minha casa
era aquela musicada todo o domingo era
maravilhoso
isso foi muito incrível pra mim porque
eu vi que através da arte da cultura e
da palavra também era uma boa forma de
você contar sua história né
e é uma forma que eu tinha de me
conectar com histórias de pessoas que
pediam da minha família quando eu vi a
cartola falar daquele jeito não era só a
mensagem que eu estava passando na hora
tipo de história que estava contando mas
o jeito que ele falava por ser do jeito
que ele é
sabia que ele falava era tão genuíno que
aquilo já mostrava muita coisa da
história dele porque todos esses
detalhes fazem parte da nossa história
aí já viu né
eu não queria mais só saber procurar
saber qual era a minha história eu
queria contar a história agora né
o negócio ficou um pouco mais emocionado
aí com 16 anos entrei na faculdade de
ciências sociais não foi lá a melhor
forma para eu contar minha história do
jeito que eu queria
porque a gente olha veja só eu realmente
tira uma nota ótima em redação no enem
eu juro
só que ainda fala nós e tipo assim é é
um fala nós porque eu não sei eu sei mas
não tem tradicionalmente é nós não é a
somos nós ou é a gente é nóis é nóis
janeiro
tipo assim a gestão
o correto a junção desses singular com
esse pluralismo tipo mano
isso é muito poético só quem é mãe sabe
como é que ele sair por isso eu fui
vendo que a gente criava coisas em cada
favela desse país tem um dialeto sendo
criada e isso é incrível porque se não é
de hoje
quando vieram hoje português falando que
a gente fala português se a gente
colocar o argentino ficou calado ou na
frase é eu fiz cafuné no moleque a tele
cochilar cafuné moleque eo chefão
palavras que bunda ou seja nós estamos
até hoje dentro da nossa língua
palavras que são trazidas tanto da
áfrica tanto da cultura indígena
nós somos criativos dentro dessa
história
nós não somos só aquela galerinha
passiva que é o outro lado da história
não a gente é criativo isso não é só
dentro da cultura musical mas dentro de
todas as áreas de conhecimento
nós trazemos conhecimento para isso ai
pronto eu não queria mais só com a
história eu queria fazer história
é isso eu não faço da história aí eu
pensei negócio chamado e plantou hoje ou
points lan não sei a tradutora vai me
ajudar nisso depois só que é um negócio
meio de chicago parece que falava no
grande teatro não é sobre mim é poesia
só que eu não me identificava muito com
essa área que é que era de chicago eua
identificaram muito naquilo é a cultura
criou sabe criou são contadores de
histórias da áfrica e eu vi que isso não
era à toa
dentro da cultura africana a história
oral era um marco é um passo eu sou de
candomblé e candomblé uma religião que é
o tal e tem liturgia ela simplesmente
foi passada perpetuada através da fala e
tipo tudo bem só acontece porque tiraram
os acessos dos escravos a escrita
isso é bem violento eu gosto muito de
escrever mas eu sempre achei que falar
um pouquinho mais que ter essa troca ter
essa parada isso sempre sempre mexeu um
pouco mais simples
com que as pessoas se conectassem mais
uma com as outras
isso relatou ana este álbum central pra
mim e essa energia muito importante pra
mim não é algo só histórico bonitinho se
dizer pra mim realmente quer dizer
alguma coisa e com isso eu queria muito
que vocês soubessem que tipo
nós não somos só a resistência da
história mas nós somos seres que
existiram e criaram coisas e tem coisas
a dizer incríveis e simplesmente ignorar
essa história não é só ignorar a
história do outro mas ignorar a história
de todos nós é ignorar o jeito que todos
nós amamos todos nós falamos todos nós
desistimos porque somos seres ativos na
história somos seres que criaram toda
essa cultura essa cultura também a nossa
tem conhecimento de pessoas negras de
pessoas indígenas em todo lugar dentro
dessa cultura brasileira gente então é
muito importante que a história não seja
apagada porque a gente sabe muito bem o
que aconteceu na inglaterra no século 20
mas não sabia o que estava acontecendo
na áfrica enquanto o brasil está sendo
colonizado a gente não sabe que estava
acontecendo nos quilombos e hoje em dia
a gente não sabe que está acontecendo na
favela e geralmente a arte e todas as
culturas orais desse país tem papel aí
está falando que está acontecendo ea
mídia não mostra e academia também não
tem muitas formas de falar porque quem
tem que contar uma história sou eu tão
importante quanto saber a minha história
é o teu poder de contá lá e falar em
primeira pessoa porque eu tenho a
propriedade de contar essa história
isso é muito importante e eu queria
saber é vocês querem saber a história
mais altas são poucos
pelo menos eu soubesse seu verdadeiro
sobrenome meu país minha terra
se eu soubesse já era minha cara fosse
vista diferentes e olhar fosse mais
dançante
se eu não tivesse que ser forte a
independência da corte antes do diabo
que me pintar possível que sou da deusa
que o cultivo
pelo mesmo motivo fosse pessoa a pessoa
antes de mulatas e não tivesse que falar
na lata
se não tiver de gritar a ideia que
grassa na versão gratuita
só quero que me vingar vocês acham que
não lembrava do estupro da escrava
vocês ainda a comemoração porque o
resultado além da miscigenação
vocês acham que não esquece a tragédia
dos mac mac que termina lá no cytotec e
ela crucificado 16 sem a ajuda de nenhum
de vocês
sozinha pedindo o céu da ajuda de mãe
aninha
mas aqui só tinha em ferro e julgamento
e terra
se não vai para a prisão pode provar um
taxada de [ __ ] na televisão pra nós
ninguém reserva oração tudo preto tem
bandeira branca na trama que já sentiu
na grama
outro a respeito de toda a família pede
bênção pra mãe nosso minha filha é dizer
não gosta de mulheres gostam é de buscar
ceta de preferência branca mas com bunda
de preta até serve como lata mas foi que
tinha carta e os manos sempre desfrutou
de errado e que apesar de aliado mas a
gente tem que entender nosso lado nós
não atura papo de mandado é que o papo
não faz curva que o papel reto e vai se
arrepender de me fazer de objeto não
estou aqui pra fazer o número fica ereto
não se esqueça tinha muita treta se teu
palcos como minha [ __ ] bandeira negra
é que eu não aguento mais
será que um dia tem pai será sempre mais
jazz no cais se o torrô do valongo
quilombo dor é o combo do meu terror mas
você não me parou o esgoto na terra mais
vivo na memória eu conto aqui é para
lembrar essa história porque eu tenho a
minha rainha base para ser feliz eu
invado não me encaixo a eu gostei de
viajar muito nash na nunca viu street
cobra em couro de lobo zona que correr o
bicho pega se ficar o bicho come o que
eu passei na vida no estado como é pra
viver a minha pele é que tem que ser
muito maior muito mulher
[Aplausos]
cada
ufa
[Aplausos]